[Music]
right come on let's be honest pork is
such a versatile and delicious protein
and with just some very small steps
trust me you can elevate that dish to a
culinary masterpiece even in 10 minutes
right oscar pandan let me show you the
ingredients pork tenderloin the nice
thing about this part of the pork it's
almost like the pork fillet okay very
very lean incredibly healthy but more
importantly
cooks within like three or four minutes
beautiful slices of prosciutto
beautiful fresh corn red onions we're
going to do a nice sort of
it's almost like a corn roasted salsa
beautiful
herloom cherry tomatoes a little touch
of chili oil
fresh spinach fresh basil touch of
butter and this is my secret ingredient
it's a little bit of garlic powder that
absolutely elevates pork to a whole new
level right let's have 10 minutes on the
clock
pan on the salsa needs to have
texture it needs to get a little bit of
sort of char
best way
literally try and keep it whole okay
keep your kernels down and just sort of
be quite vigorous and don't worry about
slicing
them off into tiny little particles just
literally hold
the kernel up
and then literally
down
now
scrape into that husk okay what we're
looking for is the ribs
how do i get that char to begin with
lightly season the pan okay
throw that corn in there and get it
toasting
so it becomes salty
charred and a little bit of flavor
as you know there's no
oil in there yet because i want to char
it and that starts getting the outside
bursting with flavor
as that's taking place
i love using red onion
in
salsa top until the onion
slice it in half and just
nicely
slice don't go too thin
if it goes too thin
it actually starts
to sort of overcook
onions in
charred again dry pan
really important dry pan you'll see why
in a minute that's where that flavor is
going to come from
next
get your cherry tomatoes okay
and literally just slice these in half i
want to blister these
okay
and the nice thing about these tomatoes
they're so soft
succulent
but incredibly juicy
don't throw them in too early okay
bursting with flavor
they are so ripe it's beautiful i like
to just season those tomatoes before
they go in there that'll help them to
sort of bleed take out that incredible
moisture and intensify the flavor
now look at this
pan down pan down please pan down oscar
look cha cha cha cha cha okay
everything's getting nice and charred
over there
a
little hint of dried chili
salsas need a lift they need a bit of a
oomph and a bit of sort of a you know
a sort of a kickback and that dry chili
in there goes beautifully well
get your pork lightly season it with
salt
and pepper
i like that coarse pepper pork
you know you gotta gotta give it color
to get some flavor in there and then
look dust it both sides with that
beautiful garlic powder that makes the
pork a little bit spicy
again dust dust dust and you'll see when
we come to saute this it gets that
really nice crisp flavor
now again
season
leave them almost lightly dredged in
that but now look at this char
okay it's now drying out and charring
it's bursting
pan
nice and hot with a tenderloin
this
pork tenderloin
okay i promise you you can finish
pink okay it doesn't need lots of
cooking it just needs a nice quick sear
and look that spicy beautiful onion
powder
gives it exactly
the nice
color it deserves in
start off at 12 o'clock
all the way around
and that nice caramelized
pork
is delicious get all that in there as
well in time please
wow so three and a half minutes gone
now don't turn that pork okay
do not turn that
look
twelve
one o'clock two o'clock three o'clock i
want some color on that pork
doesn't need messing around before i
turn it a small knob
of butter okay
and she goes just around the outside in
and look my corn is actually popping now
but
pan down please oscar look at the char
on that there's nothing in there it's
just charred beautifully really
beautiful now spoon on and flick that
pork over
the secret behind this pork is letting
it rest but look at the color on that
pan down oscar oscar pan down please
pan down pan down beautiful honestly
oscar but hate yourself otherwise i'll
get megan back
now
from there we'll start that salsa moving
i've got that nice charred beautiful
flavor
okay in with a touch of oil
now you can hear it coming alive look
she's letting you know
in with a touch of chili oil now it's
coming alive
now i put my tomatoes in time please
halfway
off
snap crackle and pop look at the color
on that
beautiful
really beautiful
now pork
is going to take literally 45 seconds
each side
and it's a filet okay so treat it like
you're cooking a filler steak
out
and then literally onto the plate
and get that draining okay really
important
out and drain
that garlic smells delicious
pan back on the heat give that a little
wipe
wipe it out
now look at this
with a salsa
turn that gas off okay
that smell is delicious
i'm gonna fold in some of my spinach
my fresh basil okay
get that pan nice and hot and then look
delays the salsa for the touch of
vinegar
it's gonna bring it all together
beautifully
and now on top of that with the olive
oil
and all of a sudden we've got this nice
beautiful layer but look at that the
spinach is melting throughout
the char on that corn is just incredible
and look
let it sit there let it sit and almost
marinate
now prosciutto time please
oil into the pan i want a little bit of
crispy
texture to this pork okay in she goes
and these are so
tasty
especially when they're nice and crispy
lathe into the pan
and then literally
15 seconds each side
and look
on
it's like sort of posh bacon nice and
crispy and it gives a lovely texture
and it's pork on pork but just with a
different dimension
a little touch of kitchen roll
that helps get it really nice and crispy
and that's it look out
over
and the smell of that is incredible let
me tell you
i mean look at that
beautiful onto the kitchen paper that
gets it even crispier drains off any
excess fat
and look finally the big one
i like to give that a touch of seasoning
as it starts to cool down that salt
sticks to it off with the pan
and beautiful
the poshest bacon in town
now
time please
this is the exciting part look at that
salsa
all you do is just
place that
in the center
okay
it's marinating beautifully
it's popped in color i'm gonna put a
nice layer of that crispy
prosciutto on there
i'm gonna get my pork and sit that
just on top
literally
and then one more
and then from there it's gonna drizzle
a touch more of my salsa on top
and then literally
that corn smells delicious
a little touch of olive oil
on the outside
a little touch
of my chili oil just
dab almost like dabbing it time please
and then literally just kiss that
with a touch
ball on top
and then finally look
here this
oh boy
that
is just music
and these beautiful little bits around
and that honestly has to be one of the
most delicious pork tenderloins anywhere
in the country in under 10 minutes bon
appetit
to all of you thank you for watching
ramsey intent if i went too quick i
apologize but slow it down now don't
forget to pick up ramsey and ten
cookbook inspired by this series and
trust me you're gonna come out a much
better chef and if you like this video
don't forget to subscribe to my amazing
youtube channel for more good luck